the movie is divided into three
distinctive stories all of which revolve
around Mighty kings in the first story
we are taken to a kingdom named long
trellis where the king and queen happily
reside they are very popular among the
common folk because of their
kind-hearted and selfless Natures it's
almost like a fairy tale story with all
the good things in abundance however
there is one small problem due to an
extremely rare medical condition the
queen is told that she will never become
a mother the king tried everything to
make her better he summoned the best
doctors from far away lands conducted
expensive rituals prayed to God day and
night but to no avail no one has even
come close to diagnosing her condition
because of this the queen starts
plunging into a state of depression she
also becomes more aggressive constantly
getting into arguments and throwing
things around like a 10 year old but
little did she know that her life is
about to change dramatically one night a
mysterious man in a black robe comes to
the castle claiming that he can cure the
queen this leaves the royal couple stunt
and the King angrily asks if he's joking
the mysterious man replies that the
queen can surely have a baby but for
that the King has to go through a lot of
trouble he may even have to endure a lot
of pain following this the Man reveals
that he has been curing people using his
vast knowledge of nature he explains
that nature should always be in Balance
if someone desires a life they will have
to sacrifice one the king and queen are
both fascinated and horrified by his
words they cannot believe that
sacrificing a life is the only way to
solve their problem but due to their
desperation they agree go ahead kill one
of the peons we don't even know their
names with this the strange man starts
describing the unusual process according
to him the cure to the Queen's illness
lies within a Sea Monster's heart the
king will have to find it slay it and
extract its heart then an unmarried and
pure lady will prepare it before being
given to the queen for consumption the
strange man is adamant that this will
solve her pregnancy problem the next day
the king and marks on his mission to
find the sea monster he locates it in
his pants no in a nearby River waits for
it to fall asleep and stealthily enters
the water to launch his attack the king
then stabs the monster with a sword
puncturing its vital organs but in the
ensuing tussle he is tossed around like
a ragdoll at the end of the encounter
the Beast is slain and the king is left
with fatal injuries before he passes
away though he manages to extract the
heart from the monster following this a
dejected Queen carries the heart and
leaves hopeful that the sacrifice will
come to fruition in the next scene a
pure and unmarried maid is discovered in
the castle and she has chosen to prepare
the heart but while cooking she
experiences weird Sensations and
unexpectedly becomes pregnant
when the Queen ingests the prepared
heart she also becomes pregnant bringing
hope and Joy To The Kingdom nine months
later both the women give birth to their
sons at the same time it's almost as if
they are twins the queen names her son
Elias whereas the maid's son is Jonah
fast forward 16 years the boys have now
become adults their hair's white tone
represents the Sea Monster's Heritage
and they share a deep and unbreakable
bond of friendship they are even capable
of breathing underwater just like a fish
however the queen doesn't like her son
Elias spending time with the maid's son
Jonah she constantly chastises him to
make better friends but he pays no heed
to her words when nothing works the
queen threatens the maid to keep her son
away from Elias failing to do so will
result in the expulsion of both from the
kingdom but despite the stern warning
the boys continue meeting each other one
day they decide to pull a prank on the
queen Jonah wears Elias's clothing and
pretends to be her son but unfortunately
she quickly finds out about this as a
punishment she Exiles Jonah from the
kingdom a heartbroken Elias tries his
best to stop him but to no avail before
leaving though Jonah cuts off a tree
with his knife allowing water to flow
from there he then tells Elias that he
will be safe and sound as long as the
water is clean what after this the two
you bit an emotional goodbye promising
to meet each other soon from that day
onwards Elias regularly inspects the
tree to see the first few weeks nothing
happens but then the water suddenly
turns red realizing that his friend is
in danger Elias quickly leaves the
kingdom without informing his mother
after days of intense search he finally
arrives at Jonah's house the latter has
married a beautiful young woman who
immediately hugs Elias mistaking him for
her husband however when the prince
reveals that he is a different person
she becomes upset the woman then
explains that Jonah ventured deep into
the forest five days ago and has not
returned since worried that something
might have happened to his best friend
Elias immediately sets off to look for
him on the other hand with her only son
missing the queen visits the strange man
once again seeking help but even this
time he tells the same thing in order to
have a life she must sacrifice one
without any other options she accepts
the terms meanwhile Jonah is stranded in
a dark cave injured and scared it is
revealed that a flying creature is after
him just when we think the boy is about
to be killed Elias arrives at the scene
and fights off the creature with his
sword he even manages to kill it using
his bravery and Valor however in a
shocking turn of events it is shown that
the creature was actually his own mother
she sacrificed herself for the sake of
her son in the last scene the two
returned to their Kingdom and Elias
finally ascends to the throne ready to
lead their people into a new era
following this the Second Story begins
and we are introduced to an extremely
lustful and arrogant King he is always
surrounded by ladies and booze
completely Carefree about what is
happening in his kingdom the one thing
he is missing is a loving wife and some
dignity which shouldn't be too hard to
find considering his enormous influence
and Fortune then we are introduced to
two elderly sisters who reside in close
proximity to the Palace despite their
Advanced age and solitary existence
their voices sound strikingly youthful
and pleasing to the ear one of the
sisters Dora is a cunning and
self-centered woman while the other IMA
is Frank and since Seer and her demeanor
the sisters rarely venture out of their
house and remain unmarried seemingly
content to live out the remaining years
in seclusion one morning as Dora is
singing The King hears her voice and
instantly falls in love with her he has
never heard anyone sing so beautifully
ah you go home King you're drunk so he
arrives outside her house hoping to see
her in person however when the king
knocks on the door the sisters Panic not
wanting to expose their real appearance
they frantically think of an excuse and
Dora requests the king to come back in a
week saying she will be more comfortable
than Smitten by her voice once again he
delightfully agrees as the day of the
king's visit approaches Dora and emo
work tirelessly to make their fingers
look young and beautiful Dora tries
covering her fingers with herbs but to
no avail they still look wrinkled and
old IMA on the other hand has put her
finger in her mouth for many days and it
looks quite good and Young when the king
arrives Dora nervously presents EMA's
finger as her own hoping to deceive him
to her surprise the king is completely
Smitten by the Young and beautiful
finger and believes that he has found
the love of his life
I just love fingers
however the sisters are not out of
danger yet if the king discovers the
truth they will surely face dire
consequences so after much deliberation
Dora proposes a condition to the king
she will only sleep with him if it is in
complete darkness and the King agrees
I'm blackout right now says the king the
next scene EMA begins tightening Dora's
body with glue hoping to make her appear
like a young girl once again at midnight
a guard from the palace arrives in the
darkness and takes Dora away the king
sleeps with her and has a great time
unaware of the deception but in the
morning when he finally learns of the
truth he angrily orders his guards to
throw Dora out of the window fortunately
lock is on her side and she survives the
Fall by getting stuck in a tree after a
while something magical happens a witch
approaches Dora and transforms her into
a stunning young lady with long luscious
hair the following day as the king is
hunting in the woods he spots the
beautiful version of Dora and gets
captivated by her once again he believes
that he has found the love of his life
so he brings her to his castle intending
to make her the queen on the wedding day
IMA is also invited and as soon as she
notices her youthful sister she is taken
aback she inquires how it can be
possible to which Dora jokingly replies
that she peeled off her old skin
unfortunately emo believes this to be
true so she seeks out an iron Smith to
remove her own skin in exchange for a
necklace the latter obliges without any
hesitation and he brutally carries out
the procedure in the woods growth after
a while Emma returns to the castle all
bloodied and weak she soon passes away
due to her injuries even her sister Dora
doesn't get a happy ending as the magic
begins to fade and she slowly reverts to
her old self not wanting to cause any
further problems she runs away from her
own wedding never to be seen again the
moral of that one is never try to please
an alcoholic in the third Story the king
is extremely childish and strange his
wife died long ago and the only person
left in his family is his unmarried
daughter but for some reason he doesn't
love her wholeheartedly one day the king
notices a parasitic insect feeding on
his hand and instead of swatting it away
he allows it to continue feels good he
even takes the strange decision to keep
the parasite in a glass box and feed it
with his own blood every day as time
passes the insect grows larger and more
menacing the king becomes so engrossed
with it that he neglects his daughter's
well-being but one day the Beloved
parasite Falls sick and passes away
unable to divert his mind from the
tragedy the king finally decides to
marry his daughter Violet wait what he
decides to host a grand competition with
the winner earning the honor of marrying
the princess oh he's not me okay the
latter is both excited and apprehensive
about the idea as she had never hoped to
find love on her own terms nevertheless
she agrees to participate and the News
spreads throughout the kingdom
surprisingly the king peels out the dead
parasite skin and displays it in his
Palace he then announces that whosoever
can guess the name of the insect will
win it's Douglas hi named him to Douglas
because I love him so much hundreds of
people flood the palace hopeful that
they can marry the princess however none
possess the wisdom and know how to guess
the mysterious insect's name this upsets
the king and just when it appears as if
his daughter will remain a bachelor
someone steps up an ogre arrives at the
castle and guesses the insect's name
correctly realizing that she has to
marry an ugly beast Violet tries to
commit the unthinkable but her father
quickly calms her down and convinces her
to go through with it following this the
ogre takes a violet to his Abode which
is a cave high up in the mountains he
feeds her nothing but raw meat and keeps
her confined at all times but one day
while he is out hunting Violet sees a
woman on the adjacent mountain and
becomes happy she explains her situation
and begs for help and the woman promises
to return with backup the next day she
returns with her family and successfully
rescues Violet however along the way the
giant ogre catches up to them and
brutally pawns the family one by one he
then takes a violet to a cave and hugs
her passionately but when the ogre is
distracted she takes out a knife and
kills him once and for all in the final
scene a bloodied Violet returns to her
castle with the ogre's head in her hand
the sight terrifies everyone and even
the king falls to his knees asking for
forgiveness Violet simply says this is
the husband you chose and starts crying
the story and the entire movie ends as
Violet is appointed as the queen of the
Kingdom that one doesn't have a moral
that was just that was badass
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching